Довгі чвари між прем’єр-міністром Володимиром Гройсманом
та головою НАК "Нафтогаз" Андрієм Коболєвим
щодо ціни на газ для населення закінчились мировою.
Очільник уряду заявив, що з 1 травня блакитне паливо
для населення стане дешевшим.
НАК "Нафтогаз України"
заявив, що "Нафтогаз" мене почув.
Вони зменшують з першого травня
на 300 гривень ціну на 1000 кубів.
Нині в Україні діють дві постанови,
які регулюють ціну газу для населення.
Першою постановою у жовтні минулого року
уряд зобов’язав "Нафтогаз" продавати газ населенню
на двадцять три з половиною відсотки дорожче -
за фіксованою ціною у 8550  гривень за тисячу кубів.
А другою - у квітні цього року -
знизити ціну на 300 гривень. Але при цьому
попередню постанову про підвищення уряд не скасовував,
оскільки вона була обов’язковою в переговорах з МВФ.
Ба більше. Згідно зі старою постановою, блакитне паливо
мало ще подорожчати - у травні та наприкінці цього року.
Саме на цю суперечливість постанов посилався "Нафтогаз"
у перепалках з урядом, не розуміючи яку з них має виконувати.
Втім прем’єр-міністр не самовільно почав вимагати
зниження вартості блакитного палива для населення.
На зовнішніх ринках ціни на газ і нафту впали.
В першу чергу через теплу зиму і великий залишок блакитного палива у сховищах.
Таким чином,  ринкова ціна стала нижчою,
ніж та, що визначена урядом. Окрім того,
вперше ціна для промисловості в Україні
могла стати меншою, ніж для населення.
А це могло б викликати обурення у людей
і суттєво знизити рейтинг прем’єра перед наступними парламентськими виборами,
куди він готується йти зі своєю політичною силою.
Фактично про зниження ціни вперше заговорив сам НАК "Нафтогаз України".
Ще у березні він запропонував уряду перейти повністю на ринкове формування -
як для промисловості, так і для населення, тобто для всіх споживачів.
Це саме те, чого вимагає МВФ.
Це б дало можливість не підвищувати ціни для населення,
як це зобов'язувала минулорічна постанова уряду.
Однак, це б також означало, що якби ціни на ринку
в майбутньому пішли вгору, довелося б так само
знову підвищувати ціну на газ для населення.
Саме тому уряд з такою пропозицією не погодився.
Натомість Кабмін запропонував свій варіант -
фактично регулювання ціни на газ для населення у ручному режимі.
Згідно з останньою постановою, якщо ринкові ціни знижуються,
"Нафтогаз" мусить продавати населенню газ
за тією самою ціною, що й для промисловості.
А якщо ціна для промисловості зростає,
компанія має продавати газ для населення за ціною,
не вище тієї, що була встановлена в минулорічній постанові -
8550 гривень за тисячу кубометрів.
Формально прем'єр-міністр Володимир Гройсман
справді вплинув на зниження ціни на газ для населення.
Але головна причина - зовнішні чинники здешевлення газу та нафти на ринку.
Крім того, домовленість щодо зниження ціни на газ з 1 травня
має термін дії лише до кінця року.
Тож, є явні ознаки протримати таку ціну до виборів попри домовленості з МВФ,
вважають оглядачі. Як ціна на газ регулюватиметься наступного року,
коли вибори закінчаться, не відомо.